au château de versailles ce lundi s'est
déroulée la première édition en france
du trianon start-up une première dans le
cadre du dialogue de trianon dont
l'objectif est d'intensifier les
échanges entre les sociétés civiles des
deux pays dans une grande variété de
domaines initiative lancée par les
président emmanuel macron et vladimir
poutine en mai 2010 est il avait lancé
l'idée que les sociétés civiles des deux
pays se rencontrent et on nous a demandé
donc avec un conseil de coordination
moitié français moitié russe 15 15
allez-y on vous donne le coup d'envoi et
trouver des formules originales pour
permettre des rencontres la journée
trianon start-up revisite le concept du
forum travailler ensemble 30 start-up
russes ont fait le déplacement
en face de ces jeunes pousses une
quinzaine d'entreprises françaises
étaient présents tels que thales air
france total ou encore air liquide
il se rend compte pour desserrer de
courtes entrevues qu'a pas de différence
entre les grands groupes et les startups
tout le monde change tout le monde
tourne et se rencontrent donc pendant 20
minutes trois minutes avant la fin des
rendez-vous on sonne une première fois
les cloches et après on les ressort une
deuxième fois elle la deuxième fois
c'est le moment où il faut changer de
table et se diriger vers le rendez vous
sur vos l'espère c'est évidemment faire
des rencontres comme d'habitude des
rencontres de qualité et qui se suivront
par des études d'opportunité et pourquoi
pas des partenariats fructueux pour nous
deux à la fin de cette journée les
participants ont pu identifier un
partenaire ou un projet concret afin
d'amorcer rapidement une relation
d'affaires linverse va se produire c'est
à dire que les start up française
iront alors rencontrer les grandes
entreprises russes et c'est exactement
la vocation d'un dialogue
à noter donc dans les agendas la
prochaine rencontre entre les deux pays
est fixé pour l'automne à moscou